- [Narrator] The Russia Ukraine crisis
is causing uncertainty
in natural case markets.
As Western countries
weigh potential sanctions
against Moscow, the
future of Nord Stream 2,
the Russian-built pipeline
in the Baltic Sea,
has been brought into question.
- When it comes to Nord Stream 2,
the pipeline that would bring natural gas
from Russia to Germany,
if Russia further invades Ukraine,
it will not happen.
- [Narrator] But in Europe, the
picture is more complicated.
That's because about 40% of
the continent's gas imports
used to generate power
for heating, cooling
and for some industrial
processes come from Russia.
- Europe absolutely has
huge interdependence
with Russia on gas.
And it really is an interdependence.
- [Narrator] The pipeline is
awaiting approval to operate
from German and EU regulators.
If granted, it will double the capacity
of an existing pipeline in the region.
- People are saying you've
got the Nord Stream 1 link,
why do you need a Nord Stream 2?
A second link in the eyes of critics
will increase the dependence
of Germany and Europe on
Russian energy exports.
- [Narrator] Concerns
that supplies to Europe
will be affected by the tensions come
as European and Asian prices
for the commodity soured
amid winter supply shortages.
So how does the rising demand
and tensions in the region
have rippling effects
on the global market,
including on US efforts
to plug the supply gap?
Officials in the Biden, Trump
and Obama administrations
have opposed Nord Stream 2 over fears
that it would enhance Moscow's
political sway in Europe.
- We don't want Europe's energy supplies
to be dependent on Vladimir Putin.
- [Narrator] Now fresh threats from the US
to halt the 765-mile-long
underwater system are under way
as Russia amasses troops and
weapons on Ukraine's border.
- And as geopolitical
tensions are increasing
around Ukraine, Russia
invaded Ukraine already once
in 2014, annexed part of its territory,
the Crimean Peninsula.
- [Narrator] Sanctions
were placed on Moscow
from Western countries, including Germany
following that military action
but the financial penalties
didn't include gas.
- Now the United States are saying
that this time around,
we should push for broader sanctions
if Russia attacks Ukraine again
and we should include energy.
So essentially, the pipeline
is at the middle of all this.
- [Narrator] Russia has been
pushing for the pipeline
to be approved as gas in Europe
has been in short supply.
That's partly because Gazprom,
Moscow's state-run supplier,
refilled domestic inventories
and allowed its sizeable storage Europe
to run unusually low.
President Vladimir Putin
said quick approval
of the Nord Stream 2 pipeline
would help rebalance the European market.
Those comments exacerbated hawkish fears
that Moscow might be weaponizing energy.
- A limited supply of
Russian gas in Europe
has added to the global demand for gas.
And specifically, liquified natural gas
that can be shipped from other places.
So the liquefying natural gas facilities
in the US just going at full tilt
to try and meet as much of
that demand as they could.
- [Narrator] US gas prices have risen
because more gases is being exported.
But the total production
of all existing facilities
can only export a maximum of around 12%.
The rest is sold at home,
keeping US prices mostly insulated
from international ones.
Any US sanctions targeting
natural gas in Russia
could come at a cost for Europe,
which may struggle to
find quick alternatives
of the supply.
However, those penalties are unlikely
to be put in place by President Biden.
- It's more likely that
they will reach some sort
of compromise, and the
Germans are saying look,
if there is a Russian
aggression in Ukraine,
if the Russians march in again
into their neighboring country,
then we will stop the pipeline.